so
all right he knows he's stuck
roger he pulled into the driveway
standby
all right he's going south on 30 seconds
oh yeah
with the task force up there we're
trying to get there now
all right thank you
they're calling anywhere
oh
[Music]
all right he's in indian river county
now continuing north uh he's passing on
double solids
indian river county is in the pursuit
currently
i'll keep updating you as i get
he's at ninth at 43rd he's going to blow
through the traffic light
all right indian river is back in
pursuit they are closing on their own
vehicle currently still uh westbound on
ninth
classes street street southwest unit
there's no way out
so just keep an eye on because you don't
need to have to fail or turn around
roger that he's turning uh east i'm
sorry yes east on 21st it's the
second to last road he's running out of
room real fast
all right that road dead ends indian
river county still behind him
any river wants to know where you have
them at right now
we're all the way down at the very
southern and the 21st uh and he's by
himself and he's gonna need backup
he's near seven
six
nine five twenty first
that's gonna circle back around so he's
gonna head back out we need to get into
river county to start closing off that
road
none of these roads have names he's uh
he did a u-turn he's headed back out
of this uh enclosure this this captive
area
in the river county that you're gonna
stop right there if he can stop the unit
that was coming down 21st or whatever
the indoor county youth that just made a
u-turn is right there coming up back up
north right towards you
all right he's gonna come back out on
21st street that unit right there he's
coming at you
[Music]
oh
but he's back westbound on 21st
everywhere he tries to come out here
there's no way they don't kill
all right he's coming out on 20 or 86
86th avenue he's going to be northbound
on 86.
all right standby
right turn on an unnamed
right turn
[Music]
right turn on 17th they're trying to fit
alright he's going into this
[Music]
he's attempting to drive through the
woods
everyone has no visual i've got two
indian rivers uh they have canine but
he's in the woods i've got no visual on
that vehicle
161's got it
[Music]
got it
that's the right in my customer
431-1610